welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Vanka Shore professor of
environmental governance and political
science at Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies his research
interests focus on non-state market
driven environmental governance and
impact and opportunities of
globalization and internationalization
on domestic and local environmental
policy corporate sustainability
initiatives and comparative
environmental policy he is a prolific
author of books and articles that
integrate public policy corporate social
responsibility and international
environmental governance today we will
talk with him about global forest
governance
welcome professor Koecher thank you so
you have recently written a paper which
we'll get to in a minute but let's talk
about some of the key challenges to
global forest governance today sure
there are essentially two major
challenges what concerns the degradation
of global the world's forests for
example forest ecosystems are being
negatively impacted by a range of
practices from industrial logging to
illegal logging activities that make the
forest we're worse off than it used to
be and so how do we think about policies
aimed at improving forest management are
very important but secondly we also face
deforestation challenges where other
sectors from industrial palm oil
plantations to mining and so on act in
ways to reduce the forest landscape
which causes many negative externalities
and influences some forest livelihoods
and forest ecosystems
INRI permanent and negative ways the
countries where this problem is the
worst yeah it's a very good question
because every country faces important
forest challenges including North
America and Europe
we even had for example big debates over
the northern spotted owl
and its reliance on old-growth forests
in the US Pacific Northwest that came
with all kinds of debates about what
kinds of things we have to do to
preserve both jobs but also the
environment but increasingly so a lot of
attention is placed on tropical forests
where they're the subject of much
scrutiny owing to the role of
agricultural crops like palm oil causing
deforestation and also the important
role of forests dependent communities
who are increasingly facing lifelong
poverty cycles and we try to think about
how forests might help improve them in
getting out of their current situation I
imagine that it also affects the animal
populations too and forces the animals
to go other places when the forests are
cut down that's right so forest
ecosystems are home to incredible
biodiversity especially in the tropics
so from an orangutan to microbial
species where we are having the
scientists tell us negative and enduring
impacts and biodiversity loss in these
regions okay so in getting to your paper
you look at in your paper whether or not
legality verification can rescue global
forest governance so if you can tell us
what you mean by that term and also what
it means for global forests of
governance who governs it's a really
good question because for the most part
nation-states are the places in which
policies are developed to address
ongoing forest challenges and this
notion that governments have sovereign
authority to develop rules governing
problems in their own territories is
enduring principle of international
relations
however it's increasingly recognized
that we need some kind of international
cooperation around forests owing in part
to biodiversity losses that are global
in nature but also because international
trade in forest products is both causing
many problems that we are witnessing
deforestation - degradation but also
might give us the opportunity to
actually reverse those pressures and
perhaps help us find innovative
solutions to these challenges and so
what I say and ask the question can
markets rescue global forest governance
what I'm pondering is you know we've had
25 30 years of efforts internationally
on the part of the world's governments
to address deforestation and degradation
and even more recently the climate
impacts of deforestation however all
these initiatives while well intended
have not had their desired effects
there's been a lack of concerted
international cooperation that can
meaningfully address these challenges in
an enduring important way so the
question is can we develop the proper
economic incentives that might actually
encourage forest companies and those
conducting deforestation to change their
practices to be rewarded economically
for being stewards of the environment
and for reducing deforestation and
reducing climate emissions and we think
the answer is a possible yes depending
on how practitioners and government
officials come together to nurture these
kinds of processes and do you have some
kind of guidelines in order to do that
yeah so we say any effort to do this has
to recognize a really difficult dilemma
and that is the more you use market
incentives and by this I mean either eco
labeling incentives in which the very
top producers are rewarded with a label
for practicing excellent forest
practices and who are audited for
compliance to standards by third party
independent verifiers or it might mean
focusing on what we taught we refer to
as legality verification where producers
are simply recognized for addressing and
identifying legal requirements even if
they're not considered gold standard
requirements in both those cases the
conundrum is that the costs of
compliance cannot be so high that
the countervail or Trump the economic
incentives and that means that the more
you can increase economic incentives
either through customer awareness for
example consumers paying more for green
products or through government
procurement policies requiring that
anything they buy comes from sustainable
sources or other means for example
through trade agreements anything we can
do to increase the economic incentives
and requirements will actually therefore
help on the ground practices this
creates a chicken-and-egg conundrum as
you build supply and build demand
towards these sustainable products um it
is therefore any chram ental process a
back and forth process which means that
initially the impacts on the ground will
not be significant as they will be at a
later time when the market is fully
entrenched immer all buying these
certified and legal materials so how do
we get there it's very important and we
think the more that practitioners and
stakeholders and environmental groups
focus on the mechanisms for doing so for
example supply chain tracking the better
off we are in actually addressing on the
ground Forest Practices currently we're
focusing attention on what are the best
practices that ought to be implemented
on the ground which is an excellent
effort but by itself is not enough we've
had 30 years of efforts identifying the
best practices and now we need more
efforts on the mechanisms for compliance
this means for example of thinking about
technologies like DNA technology GIS
satellite imagery and even cell phone
technology to better improve the
tracking of forest products from
Indonesia from Malaysia from Africa to
North American and European consumers
who often will pay more for these kinds
of sustainable products who would be
responsible though for for that tracking
I mean who ultimately monitors all of
this there's - it's a two-part answer to
your question so the first is to think
carefully about the coalition's of
support and what we're finding is that
coalition's of what political science
refers to as bootleggers and Baptists
are emerging to support legality
verification and what this means is that
very different interests in this case
legal timber producers and environmental
activists or on the same side on this
question because both have a strategic
self interests in supporting legality
verification the illegal producer is in
the timber industry do because they
actually gain an economic benefit by
weeding out supply you end up increasing
the price and that's good for their
bottom line environmental activists see
they need to be support this to actually
weed out some of the worst practices in
the world illegally harvested timber as
a result you have very strange
bedfellows of bootleggers and Baptists
meaning two very different kinds of
groups supporting meeting during these
policies aimed at reducing illegal
logging so once they get in place the
notions of why the coalition's are
emerging and we realize that means
tending simultaneously to environmental
and economic interests then we can think
about the second question which is how
do we do it and that means developing a
system in which companies have an
incentive in being part of the tracking
process so as long as the costs of
compliance that is building tracking
systems of legally harvested timber are
smaller than the economic rents they
achieve by reducing the bad supply
companies will be in favor of helping
promote these collaborative efforts and
this means that only by having companies
government stakeholders across the world
united by these forest products supply
chains together collaborating on
tracking can we actually achieve some
kind of enduring success on the
mechanisms side of this question so help
me understand if someone is doing
illegal logging how that plays into what
you've just laid out okay thank you very
good question because what we're finding
is that illegal activity which can occur
in a number of circumstances but it's
essentially capturing those processes
where companies and individuals go into
forests
and harvest the logs without any
permission I'm doing so without any
kinds of constraints and controls about
environmental stewardship without pay
attention to annual harvest rates and so
on can lead to enduring and lasting
effects of degradation to the
environment because there's no legally
enforced environmental stewardship
taking place so by weeding out this
lumber from markets and requiring that
companies and individuals follow local
law laws about reforestation about how
to harvest in an eco sensitive way we
can start to begin to make a difference
on the ground governing these global
environmental challenges in the forest
sector so can actually lead to a win-win
opportunity where those who do produce
in a legal way may actually help address
these ongoing challenges of
deforestation and degradation versus
being part of the problem
so again though if someone has a
shipment of illegally harvested wood yes
what actually happens no one will buy it
because they know it's illegal what
exactly happens in that instance so
what's happened recently and why this is
a very important topic for students of
international regulation policy and
international trade is that both the
United States and the European Union
have passed international trade
legislation within their own territories
requiring that any importer of wood show
do care that it did not come from
illegal sources so although it's a
market mechanism the compliance
incentives come from US and EU domestic
legislation and this has created a much
more different incentive than Eco
labeling programs which relied on
goodwill on the part of consumers and
retailers to support these things it
turns out that fear of going to jail for
breaking the law is a much greater
motivator than simple goodwill wasn't in
the past
right it's one thing though to have the
UK and the u.s. have this agreement in
looking at the maps it looks like South
America China parts of Russia are really
the ones who are doing most of the
illegal stuff
so are they trading with each other and
are there no ramifications there in a
10-year period from the mid 1990s to the
mid 2000s the China increased
dramatically its imports from these key
countries were talking about Indonesia
Malaysia Gabon and so on they used that
material to manufacture products many of
which went to the US and EU markets so
in that same time frame Chinese exports
of manufactured forest products to the
United States went up 1,000% and to the
Europe 800 percent why because these are
incredibly lucrative markets so the same
markets creating pressure on China and
creating demand in Indonesia for these
products might also be the places to
find some kind of solution to these
challenges this is not simply about
Indonesia or Malaysia or Gabon making
mistakes this is about North American
and European consumption creating and
being the ultimate causes of this
destruction we're witnessing okay so
standing back what forestry challenges
do you think are best left to public
policies and which are more appropriate
for market interventions that's a great
question I would argue in the last 20
years we've placed far too great
attention on market mechanisms as
providing all the answers to our
problems that's not possible some things
markets can do very well and we would
argue for example that when it comes to
regulating commercial forest practices
in the forest sector so how to improve
your harvesting your streams how to
reforest how do maintain a sustainable
level of cut these are things that
markets could do very well by saying to
producers if you want access to our
markets or to Home Depot you have to
abide by a certain standards
okay that makes sense and we can think
about how then a global community United
around these supply chains could help
enforce those kinds of laws and
standards however when it comes to
biodiversity loss deforestation that's
often owing to other sectors for example
industrial palm oil plantations then it
seems that market mechanisms don't have
that much teeth well we spent 20 years
nurturing market mechanisms we've had
ongoing deforestation in Indonesia which
scientists have told us now equal the
same in carbon emissions alone two US
auto emissions per year okay this means
that we need much tougher I would argue
government policies when it comes to
land use designation what land is going
to be for the working forests what land
will be a set aside for biodiversity
conservation my worry is that by giving
all attention to market mechanisms we
made two fundamental errors one but
giving markets too much attention too
much responsibility
they were burdened under the weight of
too many responsibilities and therefore
they couldn't achieve more modest
objectives that could have been in place
second by giving them everything to do
we took the problem definition off of
government agendas who said simply hey
markets are addressing this question
when that was a cop-out right the
question is how do we better integrate
find synergies among government policies
on the one hand and markets on the other
hand this requires a much more concerted
effort around the problems that we all
care about and do you think it's
possible to meld the two I actually do I
think it's not easy people call me an
optimist I think I'm just much more of a
concerned problem focused political
scientist and I see possibilities for
doing so it requires that the great
coalition we now have globally that's
emerging to address legality
verification because the strategic
self-interest of so many organizations
unite around this instrument it requires
the same
coalition think carefully about then
what they can do collectively to solve
subproblems that meet other instruments
and other tools and how can we therefore
work in a synergistic a way linking
theories of why support occurs two
strategies for better improving
on-the-ground performance around these
kinds of institutions okay are there any
other efforts that you think can be
undertaken to improve flora global
forest governance yeah so there there
are a number what I would argue is most
important and which is actually
happening right now or will be happening
very soon rather at the UN F Triple C
meeting in Poland in November is that
there's now what's called a landscape
day and this is an effort to unite the
world governments and think tanks and
strategists around these very questions
about cross-sectoral interactions and
this idea is that by more carefully
learning about the science of
biodiversity conservation and loss and
about the instruments available that we
can through what it's called policy
learning among stakeholders and
governments achieve more enduring
success and this requires attention to a
policy learning architecture that is
designed not just to achieve agreement
on standards but to generate knowledge
about causal mechanisms that might
actually help address problems so I
would say policy learning architecture
is now emerging as a key way to think
about addressing these problems and it's
fundamental for developing and for
building these kinds of approaches that
might have a chance of reversing
deforestation and forest degradation
problems that all of us around the world
um Dubin must care about that is the key
I think you know well thank you so much
for being here with us today and sharing
some of your work my pleasure thank you
for more information about professor
Kishore and his research please visit
our website at yale.edu slash macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding
the Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center
for International and area studies at
Yale